hello everyone and welcome to the first
game that ended in round four it's
jordan von forest versus magnus carlson
uh in round four of the tata steel chess
tournament 2021
and i decided to show it right away uh
since it finished rather quickly
uh so one forest with the white pieces
opens with e4
and as the title suggests let's see
let's see how he does this
we have e5 by magnus knight f3 and
knight to c6 with bishop to b5
uh going for the royal opus and now we
don't see the berlin defense but rather
a6 morpheus defense with bishop to a4
knight to f6 and now uh white just
castles with b5 and bishop to b3 so this
is all very standard stuff
we see this very often bishop to b7
going for the arkhangelsk
variation and d3 uh by van forest with
bishop to e7
and knight the c3 we have castles and
now a3
all been seen before we have knight to
d4 uh now offering a trade of knights
also attacking the bishop here
and this is the this is the first moment
where when forrest
shows that uh he he came very much
prepared for this game because
uh magnus already had this position
against fabiana corwana in the 2016
granchester rapid tournament in paris
uh and he defeated fabiana caruana
caruana went bishop to a2
and magnus won that game however here we
have a trade on d4
captures captures and now uh knights the
e2
also uh interestingly in that same
tournament in the 2016
granchester paris tournament uh magnus
also had this position with the black
pieces against maxime bashir legrov who
went
knight to d5 and that game ended very
very quickly magnus
defeated mvl i think in some 26 moves
so here knight the e2 again showing a
different preparation
and magnus uh as the d4 point is under
attack defends it with c5 and here
uh there are some games where knight to
g3 was played also c3 is a known move
but here we have bishop to g5
and this is now an uh a new move in the
position so already as a move 12 we have
a completely new game
and here magnus replied with the d5 now
i was very interested
in how strong the reply is and i let
the engine crunch the position here for
some 15 minutes and it got
to the depth of 36 and it says that d5
is indeed the absolute best move and
that it should give black
a slight advantage so let's see what
happens here this is what uh van forest
prepared as
chances are he he of course also looked
into the d5 move
bishop captures on f6 bishop captures
and now
bishop captures on d5 so trading
everything off
bishop captures e captures in the queen
character so now what we have here
is that the position is very very
similar there's only the e file that is
open on the board it's
bishop against knight and uh seven pawns
each four points each on the queen side
three pawns each on the king's side we
have knights to g3
and now c4 magnus continues pushing uh
we have rook to e1
putting a rook on a nice open file and
rook eight to e8 when uh
carlson does the same uh we have a for
now uh trying to
create some weaknesses in carlson's pawn
structure and
magnus trades one so rook capture sunny
one queen captures on e1
and c captures on d3 c captures on d3
and now
b captures on a4 and now we have queen
to d1 not not capturing right away if
you capture right away
then magnus could get some queen b5
action going on here
attacking a lot of targets so instead
after b
captures on a4 we have queen to d1 now
with a double attack on the pawn here
also keeping an eye on the d3 pawn
queen to b5 by magnus and now comes
knight to e4
so what do you do here bishop to e7 if
you go
for the b2 pawn queen captures on b2 and
the be all greedy about it
then uh you're gonna allow white to open
up your king side uh
rook captures on a4 and it's gonna be uh
it's still probably a drawn end game
uh but you know you don't want to
shatter your king's defenses like this
so here after knight to e4 bishop back
to e7 by magnus
and now queen to c2 we have rooked a b8
going after that b2 pawn and of course
now white goes for the trade rook
captures magnus traits queens
captures captures and captures and now
of course you do not want to grab the a6
pawn right away you're getting
checkmated
so one for us needs to make some
breeding room for the king he goes for
g4 and now uh rook to b6 magnus defends
this pawn and gives up
the the d4 pawn uh the past a6 pawn is
much more important as it's also an
outside pass pawn so rook captures on d4
and now
king to f8 bringing the king into the
game rook to d7
and now rook to g6 going after the g
pawn here
uh there's no point defending it because
it's just f5 so doesn't really make
sense so here king to f1
and rook captures on g4 but now when
forest gets
his rook behind the pass pawn so rook to
a7
uh and now a magnus goes for f5 so f5
and now knights the g3 saying okay i'm
gonna grab this pawn
and magnus decides to defend it g6 uh
and of course rook captures on a6 so now
it's three points each but magnus will
still be able to win the d3 pawn
rook the h4 king to g2 defending the
pawn
and now rook to d4 not that rook to d4
if he went rook to d4 right away while
the king was on f1 then the king just
defends it
so here 92 attacking the rook and rook
captures on d3 and
we've traded down into this very
simplified end game where carlson has
three pawns and one for us has two
points
uh all of them on the king side so let's
see if carlson can
push for for more than a draw here
knight to g1
uh we have rook to d7 uh we have
knight to f3 and now king to g7 magnus
now needs to
find some sort of a way how to advance
with his king and push his pawns
h3 and bishop to f6 now we have king to
g3
and rook to b7 now king to g2 and
rook to e7 uh we have rook to a5 and now
rook to c7 so just uh uh reaching move
40 obviously getting getting time
control gaining more time
rook to d5 and now rook to a7 we have
rook to b5 and now
bishop to e7 uh knight to d4
and now rook to d7 attacking the knight
knight back to f3 you don't really gain
anything by delivering this check so
it'd be pointless
knight f3 and now rook to d6 uh we have
rook to b7
attacking the bishop here and now king
to f6 so slowly but surely
uh improving the position of the black
king rook the a7
and now h6 and here knights to h4 trying
to
uh trick magnus if magnus goes for
example for g5 then you just pick up the
pawn because the bishop is hanging here
captures and captures
and now it's a dead raw so after knight
h4 we have bishop back to d8 by magnus
defending his bishop
but now rook to h7 going after the pawn
going after this pawn
and here magnus needs to decide what to
do here does he want to
keep the game going with king to g5
which
then goes into knight to f3 checking
king h5 all of his pawns are still
protected
and maybe he can still continue pushing
or go for the very tricky rook to d2
but now although this looks like uh like
a very tricky idea you could maybe
go for that f2 pawn it actually doesn't
work uh for magnus because here uh rook
captures on h6 allowing king to g7 so
attacking both of the
both of the pieces not that one uh both
knight and the rook here we've reached
the position from the thumbnail
but now uh it doesn't really matter
because when forest has rook captures on
g6 king h7
and now knight to f3 uh freeing that
knight and now
the rook is under attack so that's why
that's why rook the d2 was
in fact a dead draw and the other line
still
offered some play but in the end with
with perfect play play of course would
not be enough for a win so here magnus
grabs the pawn rook captures on f2 he
doesn't want to give up
the trade for nothing uh king captures
king captures and now
king to g2 so a two piece uh one piece
each one pawn each
uh sorry not king g3 king g2 was played
king to h5 and now
knight to d4 going after the pawn we
have f4 and now again
going after the pawn and the bishop so
magnus needs to defend this
bishop to g5 and now knight captures on
g5
king captures and king to f3 now and we
reach this
king and pawn end game that is of course
a dead raw king h4
that's not an h4 king h4 and now
captures captures and
it was in this position that the players
reached a draw by
insufficient material so there you have
it a very very simple tutorial on how to
play against magnus carlsen if you ever
face him
so just uh know all of the games that he
played like when forrest did here
prepare a novelty for him so he has to
figure out what's happening over the
board
and of course play a perfect game make
no mistakes and even though
black was uh black was better for the
entire game by just a little bit
it was never enough to push for
something more than an advantage so
a very useful opening if you need if you
need a draw and
of course whenever you play magnus a
draw is more than enough
so uh a great victory for for one for us
here snatching half a point from the
world champion and uh magnus still
continues his drawing streak
after winning that brilliant game
against alireza in round one uh
then he then uh three three draws uh but
everyone plays very careful against him
uh because you know that even giving him
just a little bit a little bit of room
to breathe
uh magnus will go for that full point so
uh one for us did not allow it in this
game and he was able to
to get a very nice draw here uh so yeah
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it
uh now you know how to play against
magnus if you ever face him
uh i would like to thank divi dynamo
asian farah lewis madison
omar dasar and ryan urban for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the tata
still checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day